I'm going to urate real fast you're
going to urinate yeah that right like a
racehorse my brother you ever owned a
horse never owned a horse I'm a dog guy
really you ever bet on dogs you ever put
one in at the track honestly yes I have
yeah in Florida in fact yeah in Florida
in the ' 80s and that dog track has now
been closed and I love dogs and I've
always loved dogs and it's the one in
Miami that's near the airport and it was
the most
depressing inhumane like you wanted to
send money to pea spending 20 minutes
there but I did go there yes I had been
drinking and probably other things and I
did bet on the Greyhounds and I feel bad
about it yeah I do you ever ridden on
Greyhound I've always I've always been a
sizable man I could and they Buck me off
every time I try really yeah wheel
around and bite me yeah they they don't
it's hard to saddle a greyhound no I
mean the bus service oh sorry sorry I
thought you meant the dogs oh no oh I
spent a lot of time my actually true
story yeah I had a girlfriend in high
school um but we went to different
colleges and she went to Vanderbilt
University in Nashville Tennessee and I
I lived in New England which is a small
colder region shout will Shepard of
there go one and I took the bus I took a
Greyhound bus from Washington DC where
my parents lived to Nashville which is
like 12 hours and then I took one back
and so this bus was going on to New York
City and for some reason it was 100% p
freaking and me and I was at the back of
the bus and it left like midnight yeah
and I was drinking and smoking on the
that's how Longo was this was 1987 I'll
never forget it and I fall asleep cuz
I'm so loaded I'm taking a leak in the
empty cans you know doing what you doing
Liv life dude and all of a sudden I feel
this wet grainy thing on my face and
these people right there in the seat
right across the aisle were just like
full coitus just like oh yeah playing
couch ball just full-blown a six sound
effects everything and the guy was
wearing socks and one of the socks hit
my face and it was just moist and it had
a lot of gravel from the ground on it
and I remember thinking this is the I
can't wait to get off this
bus it was dark it was nothing erotic
about it at all oh yeah right I mean I
don't know it depends on what you're you
know how you were at the time I think
but I was drunk and in a dead sleep and
they're rolling around and she's making
these animal noise
like they were not at all inhibited
which was kind of impressive in a way
but I felt it was very much an intrusion
into my space wow yeah that's fair like
hey is there any zoning over here you're
right what yeah who yeah do we have a
town planner true that's a true story
yeah oh that's good oh Greyhound's
unbelievable dude I remember remember
one time a guy's on there right sitting
by me he goes hey uh and yeah there was
a brother on there and he goes hey you
want to see something and I thought it
was going to be um his wiener right
because I've been on the bus before and
but you said yes well it was a two-hour
ride I was like I'll [__] see it now
you know I'm not gonna pretend she
thought he cut a hole in the bottom of
the back yeah I thought I get it I get
it some wiener trick totally old
Greyhound wiener
[Laughter]
trick and uh I was like yeah I'll see it
you know and uh he had a bag of jewelry
and a gun and he just robbed a jewelry
store wow he had a bag of Jew and gun no
I didn't buy any but he wanted me to sit
there and look at it put on a couple of
the necklaces or whatever and uh did you
act impressed oh yeah cuz I was scared
and they always give the guy you know
once you if you get out of jail they
give you a ticket on the [__] gr but
imagine you rob a jewelry store and your
getaway vehicle is a Greyhound bus
unbelievable you are [__] if you're
doing that you're like we got to get out
of here in seven
hours I bought the
ticket it's pretty cool dude it was a
yeah I mean I loved riding Grand I used
to work on a farm up in uh Mississippi
and so I would take a Greyhound bus up
there and um and I would ride it up
there and there was always people on
there the bathroom like on it was always
closed they said you know um I was on
one where yeah part of it was on fire I
was on one where a guy stopped to
[__] meet his ex or something for
like 20 minutes and we all had a chill
at a eye op no way 100% dude go to
Greyhound bus Twitter feed grah us help
and look at their replies on there bro
welcome to America bro love that so it's
just like every Waffle House they stop
at oh it's just like ah the bus supposed
to leave at 4:30 it's 970 somebody like
it's
970 well you have a bad watch it be like
it's 970 two people are pregnant it's
just the list goes on man chances I'd
like the people on those buses
100% everything on you
it's
unbelievable this is but seriously all
drivers allowed my bag to be stol on
this trip where's customer service yeah
go back one they got a video let me see
that video on there I this is what I do
at night I go to Greyhound bus help
Twitter feed and they'll show stuff yeah
little eight balls between the seats or
different things there's somebody find a
gram down there between the seats did
you ever do that uh I never found any
drugs on there oh that might be somebody
touching don't let that video finish
please
but I spend a lot of time on this man
it's insane though Greyhound bus hell
it's called Greyhound bu help but yeah
they could change it it would still
work